I got myself a Toby eye tracker yes that
thing that makes you look at boobs uh
this if you can see this on my desktop
I've got a little circle and that's
showing exactly where I'm looking which
is so useful because the eyes are the
windows of truth and justice your eyes
basically tell you what you want or what
you think you want maybe what you don't
even know that you want but you can see
it now because it's in your eyes so with
this what kind of person does it say
about me of the things that I'm looking
at you know what I mean does that make
any sense it doesn't make any sense so
if I was looking at a picture and it was
this oh yes so if basically yes so that
works I
yeah think of this think of what I'm
doing right now is like a calibration to
make sure that my brain and my eyes are
working properly you know hand-eye
coordination I just want to see if it's
reflected in what we got yeah okay
nothing wrong here yeah oh my okay so
you get a general sense of like what
that is but that's not that's not that's
not the main reason about this the whole
point of this in knowing where your eyes
goes is to show you what your
preferences are because where your eye
is drawn is what really matters to you
most so what I have here are a bunch of
matchups basically pictures that I have
prepared that I don't particularly know
the order of where I have things matched
up one against the other so for example
if I close my eyes and then open them
and I looked at the puppy first
wouldn't you know it I prefer the puppy
my I was drawn to the puppy do you see
what that says about me so I'm gonna go
through these and you guys just mark
down my preferences and that will tell a
story of my soul of my true self of my
heart my deepest heart that's what that
says about me
[Music]
funny that's so cute look it not that
the Piggy's not cute the biggest cute
piggies real cute but my my I was drawn
to the bunny specifically that Bunny's
eyes I was a hunter of Star Wars okay
see it's not that I don't like Star Trek
love you Picard but you know I remember
star this cuz he's holding a gun at me
and that's not really threatening
Oh minion oh okay I'm not necessarily
expect that except maybe it's because
that minion is absolutely utterly
terrified like the eyes are just a
horror show yeah
and as much as like as as much as I as I
was inspecting
Shrek's um girth they're all kymia czar
up here
that's my Shrek impression you guys like
it um nothing to speak of down there mr.
minion huh Oh boobs V but I'm not sure
which one I went to I figured might have
been but I'm pretty sure that was
probably very much but booby but I think
this says that I'm an ass man
Oh boobs V Shrek
well boobs one by far not that I don't
not that I don't really appreciate your
boobage there
Shrek II but to be perfectly honest I
don't think that you would have won that
anyway so yeah boobs yep sorry minion
although my eyes did snap to those eyes
just in a real quick real quick little
tizzy there I think that's because
there's something very threatening about
those eyes but I think boobs still one
[Music]
puppy puppy puppy beep oh there's a big
old dick
that's quite a yeah it's quite a [ __ ]
and balls right
sorry boobs I wish it weren't so but
something about a I think this might
just be because a big old dick on your
screen ain't ain't the ain't the most is
is kind of surprising if a dick just
appears out of nowhere yeah that's why
I'm gonna go with that one
[Music]
god damn it all right you know what I
would have thought Dominion is very
phallic shaped but uh something about
that dick and balls just rely catching
oh oh no I think it's just because it's
a big red symbol I am sorry I am just
touched I have some splainin to do
[Music]
all right well this isn't a fair matchup
as charming as Felix whose smile is here
and his dapper as he looks there's still
just something shocking about a big old
dick just suddenly appearing on my
desktop just some baths very
disconcerting ah dick alright dick again
if my parents walked in on me right now
I don't think I could explain what I'm
doing because I would tell them that I'm
trying to reveal the truth of my soul
[Laughter]
[Music]
well well shiver me timbers apparently a
rock that looks like a piece warai
catching that a real penis I don't know
what the truth of my soul is and what
this says about me but boy howdy I'm
leaving dog track okay now I feel bad
because I can't say that it's because T
series was bright red logo now ah a cute
[Music]
haha alright well I think this one's
obvious just because this one's like
that's actually scary and I think I
think biologically a threat a terrifying
threat would be much more eye-catching
ah no the boobs I swear I want to look
at the boobs but it's like which pair of
eyes do I want to look at here it's
nothing it's the curse of the dick like
just a big old dick
it's just I'm sorry maybe because I'm
desensitized to this picture now but I
I'm have to replay footage and really
slow that down I will wait for the
judge's call on that one okay so I think
I revealed the truth of my soul and I'm
not sure if I'm happy with the results I
think the ranking is penis beats
everything it's like if you're playing
rock-paper-scissors but you're playing
Shrek minion boobs and penis it's like
rock paper scissors or Shrek minion and
boobs
but then penis is your friend going like
dynamite blows up everything so penis
just gets in your life and blows up
everything self dude that's my tobe
eye-tracker that's that's what that is
I don't feel too proud of myself but
anyway thank you everybody so much for
watching if you've got other ideas for
Toby stuff that I can do or stuff like a
tracker there are games out there that
are I track are enabled so if you want
to let me know what you want me to do
let me know down in the comments I've
got some ideas myself I'm gonna do that
hold don't look at boobs and butt
challenge but the hard mode it's gonna
be don't look at the penis jump which i
think is a different different challenge
entirely so anyway thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye